my personal philosophy I don't have a
motto but you know I always I always I
always dream I always take risk I try to
keep my eyes open they can be very
subtle it can be and in in in how we
construct something or you know in
business deals that that we've that
we've made or you know just moving in
with my boyfriend you know it's it's
it's they all affect each other not
really any particular risks I mean you
know I decided to move to London when I
was 17 and just go to school there
instead of sort of furthering an
academic education or you know it's it's
key back keeping your eyes open and
being listening to others and having a
dialogue with others i mean that's
that's my motto and the risk I take is
you can expose you to a lot that can
distract or affect you I mean I'm a very
open sensitive person but you also you
you have to have that conversation and
then go into isolation take that and
filter it and then go back there and
being a sponge
no I don't um dismiss religion or faith
uh you know I I'm still alive on this
planet and I think that in its truest
forms you know in some way or other I
live by sort of a mix of many religions
I you know I always believed in in
bettering who I can be and striving to a
higher place from there on on my time on
the planet so you know in some ways I
don't know if that will affect any
possibility of an afterlife in any way
but I think that's pretty similar to
foundations of Christianity and Judaism
and you know in Buddhism and you know I
don't have one one God that I that I
that I that I look up to
you